name review welcome everyone to meme
review youtube favorite show you know
when the new sonic was about to be
released everyone be like oh it's not
gonna be good and yeah everyone was
right it looked like garbage like what
is that why would you make something
like that and the internet was outraged
as they rightfully should be I mean
these are the stuff that truly matters
so they actually went and said hey sorry
oopsie oopsie we made oopsie we're gonna
go back and fix Sonic and everyone be
like okay bruh well now they did Sonic
is back and he looks epic he looks so
good oh my god no more nightmare teeth I
see this as an absolute wing
no more weirdest stinky fur no
disgusting nose everything it's
beautiful it's beautiful it's everything
I love about something paramount
listen to criticism and drops trailer
with new wood sonic design the entire
internet legit I was actually impressed
when I saw the trailer I'm like oh
actually Sonic looks really good now
oh now you look at frame by frame look
at what a difference all the expressions
and everything I don't even care about
this fell but I'm just impressed what is
that it's just some little dweeb look at
the lion left wood look at the reaction
difference - what did so much more
interesting I can't believe they went
with this oh I cannot believe they
created that originally it's now you
truly see how bad it is but man I'm I
gotta give credit like they really fixed
it up there they also changed robotic to
red because that makes sense yeah it
just I'm very happy I'm very happy for
the people that redemption this is what
redemption looks like Snickers you're
not you when you're hungry just take the
snacker what is that the tape the first
studio to listen to their fans must have
been like wow incredible first trailer
no second trailer I just kept
complaining and it worked
good job Internet you truly change lives
today you truly made an impact today
congratulations well done everyone that
complain about Sonic
you deserve a pat on the back you made
life a little less miserable internet
new sonic design that doesn't look like
a monster yes new Sonic design that
doesn't look like my sleep paralysis
demon that misses me at 3:00 a.m. when I
go up and try and get pickles the fact
they changed it and listened to people
is the reason I'm going to see the movie
good job let's get real we all would
have seen it anyway so now of course
everyone has to love this film it has to
get 10 out of 10 score even though the
plot isn't as good the voice acting is
still pretty questionable but it's worth
mentioning regardless sonic meme gets a
Redemption ball of blue it's a fine next
me
logan paul loss say it with me Logan
Paul lost I didn't fall of this second
follow-up fight I just I thought the
first one was enough but there's some
funny memes that came afterwards which I
really really appreciate there were so
many memes on the first fight but the
second fight I don't know it but there
aren't no memes I won't be there that's
the tie with it when you actually know
the answer for once but the teacher
calls on someone else
Dogen no no apparently was a split
choice with the the points again it was
really close
so I mean fair enough motive Polar's
after the fight this is so sad those
poor Logan Polar's can't believe they
lost but the real hero out of this whole
outcome it's the man that illegally
stream Logan poles versus ksi fight
through lemon ke viewers of the
reflection of his glasses
don't move bruh I think one of the
funniest things is Logan Falls reaction
to why he lost it's so good
Logan paula's explain why he lost the
fight hear my voice I'm sick I woke up
sick I've been sick for the past three I
love when people say that when they say
can you hear my voice like you sound
normal
I'm sure he was sick by the way but
still hear my voice I'm sick I woke up
sick I've been sick for the past three
days the first thing I did this morning
was sneezed three times and then I've
been sneezing throughout the whole day
I'm sick I woke up sick I've been sick
for the past three days the first thing
I did this morning was sneezed three
times and then I've been sneezing
throughout the whole day wait this is
not even the best part the best part is
when he says
nine-time times
I'm BJJ wait the math I don't understand
I thought you were poking fun of ki
about the man ten times ten what does it
mean but wait you fought him twice and
you couldn't beat him once Oh Bryce
sneeze three times I woke up I sneeze
three times come on teacher why you not
leaving home Bryce needs three times
when I woke up today do you not hear my
voice Logan Paul where is boxing career
may have caused brain damage okay fair
true alright time to rate to everyone
complaining they want numbers they want
numbers for the rating oh my god corpses
are more liable to sway from left to
right oh my god deaf stranding is out
and the reviews are in delivery
companies all around the globe love it
apparently that's the game you're just
walking through to deliver packages
amazing wow that's so cool I'm so glad I
got deaf straining so I can take a break
from real life tasks to deliver cargo
and take care of baby but nothing is
says satisfying and when you make that
delivery take it from Tobey Maguire
Pizza time
just feels good when completing a task
no matter how monotonous and boring and
tedious it is but let's get real this
game already existed long ago oh wow
there's a cat version that's cool I'll
have to check that out yeah I love the
part where you can apparently mess
around with Norman Rita's in the waiting
room
I'm so glad I have such in a supportive
husband
it's the same energy come on why can't
you stick out normally read his tongue I
don't understand
I'm so confused by this game you want to
encounter anything here
you just walk okay we have QWOP yeah
yeah a classic oh my god is created by
Hideo Kojima I love it I really like
PJ's tweet my experience with deaf
writing so far there's bridge a scene I
know what everyone is wondering why has
Felix not played this game there's
bridge S&F stranding none not for me to
be honest the game looks great I would
love to play it it seems like the kind
of game I would love to enjoy I just
know if I played it on YouTube people
would get annoyed because it's the kind
of game that isn't very eventful there's
a lot of dead gaps and walking and
people would just be like oh this is
boring I know you guys play now alright
I'll rather just play it on my own and
enjoy it on my own when I have time to
enjoy it on my own thank you that's
trending what it means what's that pop
is Moria puppies Moria hats news good
evening i'm Popish Moria I have news we
have discovered a carp with a human face
oh my god
that is the most terrifying thing ever
Oh God
I'm not the buzzer give my opinion but
that needs to die kill it kill it please
hoho god I can't live on the same planet
of this thing I've touched water before
and that thing touches water so I'm done
uh-huh I'm out Oh God why why why would
why would that live why it shouldn't
live stop making it live stop making it
live
next mmm the okay boomer mean really
took off didn't it Jesus Christ it's
been one of those memes that have been
going on for a long time on the internet
but now with the environment issues and
other frustrations just boiling up it
seems like it's really become a thing
and it's hilarious
New York Times posting okay boomer marks
the end of friendly generational
relations
I guess it's official you have all the
dumbasses or
it's clearly just bathing if you call me
a boomer you're committing a hate crime
yeah shut up shut up shut up you don't
even deserve to be called okay boomer
time to create a hate crime gamers let's
get it come on let's just do it let's do
it gamers people are now calling okay
boomer the n-word the new n-word okay
boy okay but yeh dhoop a god I kind of
low-key kind of like being stuck in
between boomers and Generation Z or
whatever I don't even know what I am
it's so much of it it's just like this
is you Zoomers
why did my reddit post not really Hong
Kong why what the hell they worked for
Sonic why Hong Kong not released and
just overall cringe humor from that I've
clearly taken part no I never endorsed
the egg joke an egg boomers reaction
what does it mean Zoomer
egg don't you get it don't you
understand and it's funny laughs here's
the real summarization of what's
happening
Gen X shut up millennial gens II okay
boomer actual boomer actual millennial
why the Frick my life hard why might the
Frick P P hard but I think the most
important part to take out of this
episode of meme review this week's name
review is are you really gonna watch
past this whole video without smashing
like and saying meow G so much like on
this video do it gamers or else I'll
slap your belly button we're all excited
about the new game that's coming out and
I can't wait to play it it starts with
the letter P can you guess what it is
here the pie pick ceiling of course what
you thought it was Pokemon dumbass you
stinky brainer
you